on february 27th paramount plus treated
viewers to an absolute pile of heartache
and devastation with the 10th episode of
1883. this is not your heaven though the
episode feels very much like a season
finale if not a series finale the
network has thus far declined to call
its officially ordered future episodes a
second season this has led some to
speculate that it's not technically a
finale of either kind whichever way you
slice it the immediate narrative
presented to viewers in the series first
10 episodes came to a gut-wrenching
conclusion on sunday with a scene that
parallels an equally moving moment in
season 1 of its predecessor series
yellowstone despite audiences knowing
from the series very first scene that
the formidable elsa dutton was destined
to be struck by an arrow her slow demise
as a result of her wound in episode 10
still came as a shock as elsa slowly
dies her father james pulls her down
from a horse drags her over to a tree
and cradles his daughter in his lap as
the two share a final exchange whether
or not fans felt the scene a fitting end
to elsa's story it was as some have
noted a fitting match with yellowstone's
recurring themes as fans of yellowstone
will recall the pilot concluded with a
similarly heartbreaking moment between
john dutton and his recently deceased
eldest son lee after lorraine lees
corpse off his horse the dutton
patriarch drags his body over to a tree
so he can share a final embrace with his
son rest a while and choose a spot for
his burial a small loud bird interrupts
their time together and serves as a kind
of symbolism for the themes of the scene
as one user pointed out on the series
subreddit jon and his great grandfather
are both sitting against the tree with
their deceased children both with a bird
other fans were quick to note the
similarity with one user adding that
both scenes involve a character saying
they want to rest for a bit there are
some differences but for the most part
the scenes are almost perfect
replications of one another by ending
the first 10 episodes of 1883 a prequel
to the events that take place during
yellowstone on the same exact note upon
which the latter essentially begins the
creators of the series have once again
foregrounded the cyclical nature of life
death and the struggle that lies in
between the death of a popular character
is usually enough to send fans up in
arms but since elsa's fate is
telegraphed by design 1883 viewers have
had the chance to brace themselves for
quite a while when the inevitable end
comes and the viewer notices that the
show has no intention of saving the
character in some far-fetched fashion
many viewers found that they actually
liked the way the show handled her death
one twitter user wrote i love how elsa
didn't just pass away and that was it we
were able to see her happy and know that
she was okay completely unexpected yet
amazing writing death is so final and
leaves you empty they managed to not
leave us me anyway with that another
user found the character in her fate
both realistic and compelling why am i
so upset about elsa in 1883 i think i
would mourn her death like she wasn't a
fictional character another user tweeted
a theory that elsa's death might be the
first in a long line of tragedies that
lee's death ties into and that
yellowstone 1932 will also feature a
chilling death in the family john dutton
in yellowstone says numerous times that
he made a promise to never sell the
ranch i'm sure that when 1932 airs about
john dutton's father and grandfather we
see this promise made from one
generation to the next and it all starts
with elsa dutton's death in 1883. it
says that it's wrong for one man to own
all this
he says you should share with all the
people yeah
could it be that the duttons have paid
the price of their ranch in blood it's a
chilling idea and it will indeed be
interesting to see whether the upcoming
1932 addresses it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]